[Musique]
jacques benillouche bonjour merci d'être
avec nous ce matin en direct sur rt
france
alors à quoi tient ce petit miracle
comment l'expliquer c'est quoi c'est une
meilleure anticipation ou une meilleure
organisation il ya cinq points bien
précis que je voudrais présenter assez
rapidement le premier point c'est la
prise de risque de natanyahou parce
qu'il a commandé alors que le vaccin
n'était pas validée par les autorités
médicales il attendait 8 millions de
doses en les payant au prix fort le
double du prix on parle de 50 $ en fait
et pour et pourtant il aurait pu avoir
la catastrophe du sanofi puisque sanofi
avait prévu en de libérer le vaccin en
masse et en fait ça ne sera pas avant
fin 20 21 et donc on lui la ville au
risque alors pourquoi il a pris ce
risque parce qu'il se dit que
financièrement c'est le coûteux mais le
coût du confinement est beaucoup plus
important que le prix du vaccin faire
parce que le point de confinement c'est
des ressources fiscales qui ne rentrent
pas pas tva pas d'exportation les
magasins fermés on doit dédommager les
employés etc
donc il a pris de risque ça c'est le
premier point que peu de gens ont voulu
prendre le deuxième point c'est que nous
avons en israël un système médical
décentralisée est totalement totalement
informatisé je dirais même digitaliser
et bien ce qui se passe c'est que vous
avez tout citoyen ce n'est un numéro qui
sert à tout un numéro unique qui sert
aussi bien pour ses comptes bancaires
que pour sa sécurité sociale que pour
l'armée et à partir de là les différents
centres de centres de sécurité sociale
ont accès plus facilement parce qu'ils
sont décentralisées dans mon quartier au
nord de tel-aviv et un centre et peut
s'occuper d'une dizaine de milliers de
personnes c'est plus facile que lorsque
c'est entièrement centralisée et donc on
nous appelle on nous téléphone on nous
envoie des sms
on nous harcèle dents
certains cas sion s'est pas inscrit et
ça c'est tout à fait différent et ce
système de décentralisation montre ses
preuves
le troisième point et c'est pas le moine
c'est que l'armée est impliqué dans
cette affaire
l'armée il y a une division spéciale
dans deux salles une division spéciale
qui est la défense passive en iran n'est
brandie piquouse aof
c'est peut-être cette division est
capable en un moment d'une journée de
monter des tentes
elle est capable de mobiliser des
médecins des étudiants
elle est capable de faire appel à du
personnel extérieur a payé ce personnel
et c'est pour ça que nous avons au
centre un peu partout autour de nous des
centres où l'on sait où on peut
s'inscrire ou on peut se faire vacciner
et vous êtes convoqué à la minute près
c'est très précis vous allez à l'heure
précise vous êtes vous êtes vacciné
vous ressortez et tout est terminé
troisième le quatrième point et là c'est
pas le moindre c'est que feiler a décidé
d'envoyer très vite des vaccins alors je
vais l'éliminer
l'histoire disant que c'est parce que le
propriétaire
le président de pfizer état juif albert
mollat et qu'il a voulu faire ça par
solidarité juive
ce n'est pas du tout le cas certes il a
peu ça a pu jouer un petit peu mais ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'israël
contient 9 millions de population et il
y à toutes les ethnies
vous avez des noirs des blancs des
études bien vous avez des gens de russie
des gens de scandinavie des gens
d'afrique du nord
des gens de france des gens d'europe
donc israël représente un petit morceau
du monde entier et freizer a dit c'est
une excellente façon de pouvoir avoir
des informations sur toutes ces
populations
les vaccinés et avant le retour ce qui
nous permettra dit-il de répercuter ces
résultats à travers le monde entier
et ça c'est pour ça en tant que
laboratoire en tant que laboratoire
naturel
eh bien ils ont eu l'autorisation de
recevoir en
unité father je dis bien en priorité les
résultats de ces tests
après le vaccin on nous appelle on ne
demande que s'est il passé
où avez-vous des douleurs enfin toutes
les répercussions sur ce qu'on peut lire
de tous les effets est-ce que les
antiquorum jouer est ce que il y a des
gens qui souffrent et ça c'est un
élément important pour pfizer parce
qu'il va répertorier ce alors le monde
le 6 le cinquième point brièvement avant
là la question suivante le le cinquième
point c'est la fierté nationale d'israël
et il serait là voulu montrer qu'il
était capable de combattre la guerre
pour lui il est habitué reggae et pour
le combat est une guerre pour lui eh
bien il a voulu par fierté montré qu'il
était le premier à réussir ce que
d'autres n'ont pas réussi maintenant il
faut dire et c'est rapide
il faut dire qu'il ya eu des
répercussions économiques très
importantes je vous donne simplement un
exemple pour finir c'est que les start
up se pullulent à l'heure actuelle au
sujet du du corona il y en a un qui
vient de réussir c'est celui qui a
consisté à à rafraîchir l'air dans les
autobus à renouveler l'air dans les
autobus pour éviter les contaminations
dans les autobus ce qui fait qu'on peut
monter dans monte dans l'autobus en
israël sans risque de se faire
contaminer et ça ils seraient tient
absolument à être le premier dans
l'armée est aussi dans la guerre du corn
oil jacques benillouche merci beaucoup
pour ces points très précis qui montre
le succès de la vaccination d'israël une
question tout de même sur les
palestiniens amnesty international
critiquent le fait qu'ils passeront en
dernier quel est votre sentiment
là-dessus
d'abord on peut dire que israël a donné
quelques vaccins jeudi quelques dizaines
je pense que ça va concerner surtout les
dirigeants mais israël il associe lente
les palestiniens sont autonomes ils ont
un budget à eux ils sont autonomes ils
ont ils ont ils veulent être autonomes
d'air et donc ils ne veulent pas se
mêler de la façon dont c'est fait pour
pouvoir faire des vaccinations il faut
enlever des israéliens
localement et les palestiniens sont
jaloux de leur autorité et donc c'est
pour ça qu'à l'heure actuelle on estime
que le pays est autonome les
palestiniens sont autonomes
ils doivent se débrouiller ils ont de
l'argent ils reçoivent d'ailleurs vous
devez le savoir aussi bien que moi
ils reçoivent énormément de vaccins
spoutnik de russie dont il reçoit aussi
des vaccins de l'onu alors les l'onu
d'un à peu près 20% des vaccinés vaccins
nécessaires et la russie a donné
pratiquement 60 à 70% des vaccins
nécessaires d'eau israël n'est pas là
pour aider israël une s l'autorité
palestinienne gérer ces problèmes de
manière autonome elle c'est une autorité
pas les siennes donc il n'y a pas si de
volonté il n'y a pas de volonté
quant aux populations arabes
israéliennes elles sont gérés de la même
façon que les populations juives
il n'ya aucune discrimination le seul
point qu'on peut signaler est on est on
a dit qu'il n'y a pas eu beaucoup de
vaccination dans les zones arabes c'est
que les populations à son très jeune et
que l'on a d'abord on s'est occupés
d'abord à ceux qui ont plus de 65 ans il
n'y a pas beaucoup de gens qui dépasse
65 ans est une minorité dans les zones
haram et il faut savoir et je terminerai
que 30% de la population médicale en
israël est d'origine arabe dont dire
qu'il y à une discrimination c'est pas
vrai puisqu'il ya une discrimination
positive au sein des universités pour
former obligatoirement 20% des étudiants
doivent être ram et c'est pour ça que
moi personnellement j'ai été vacciné par
une femme arabe une jeune quitte femme
arabe avec son voile
ça m'a pas choqué et je n'ai aucune
inquiétude merci à vous jacques
benillouche d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin dans la matinale tertre frange
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
indépendant